Chinese celebrities eat to lose weight
she lost 22 lbs in half a month and this
is how she do it for breakfast she only
drinks one black coffee with one cute
sugar for lunch she eats two boiled eggs
one tomato and boiled spinach for dinner
she eats 200 g of steak lettuce with
olive oil and some lemon juice I counted
like 800 calories Max and that's being
super generous and aside from the sugar
cube virtually no CBS that is super sad
but 11 PBS a week is Way Beyond the .5
to 1% weight loss per week it at 1 to2
pounds per week that we recommend to
reduce the risk of muscle mass loss that
generally coincides with like a 20%
calorie deficit not 50% rapid weight
loss is partially water loss but it can
also be cutting into metabolic muscle
one that he put people on a low calory
diet for 5 weeks and compared it to a
moderate deficit for 12 weeks and while
both lost the same amount of weight the
lowc calorie diet lost over six times as
much muscle mass this is why fast weight
loss is not a good thing so yeah please
don't try to lose 22 lbs in 2 weeks and
do not just eat eggs steak and lettuce
next